hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the hangzhou grand master
tournament currently being played it's a
tournament organized uh so ding could
play enough games to qualify for the for
the video candidates tournament
basically as he is the highest rated
player in the world uh except for magnus
carlsen uh and already
okay now he overtook furuja in the live
ratings as he already won five games in
this tournament uh but he is the next
one to qualify as alireza is already
qualified so it wouldn't really even
matter if alireza was higher rated than
him
so you guys requested a game from this
tournament i thought this one would be a
nice one as he's playing against his old
rival by jinxing uh if you remember in
2017 the two of them played a game that
well
many uh myself included uh
deemed ding's immortal game if you still
haven't seen it do check it out i will
put a link to it in the description
below first thing you'll see uh check it
out it's um it's from 2017 so you know
videos uh were only at 30 frames per
second back then but you know it's it's
the game that counts
uh so now let's dive into it and then
we're gonna discuss the current
situation in the world and uh well uh a
few words about the candidates
tournament and what what we know about
it so far so ding has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 we have d5 a c for
e6 knight to c3 and c5 by jin she goes
for the tara's defense and c captures on
d5 we have e captures and the knight to
f3 knight to c6 and now even though uh
uh most players play just g3 here this
is by far the the most played move here
uh d captures on c5 is the
uh preferred move even though most
people don't play it now because it just
gives the black a lot of initiative but
the ding actually plays this and he says
he wants to
win absolutely every game here which is
pretty incredible i mean even if you
imagine anyone playing against uh
well strong grandmasters and these are
grandmasters 26 50 2600 it's very hard
to beat all of them all the time but so
far ding won the first four games and he
wants to win the next one as well so d4
grabbing more space here attacking the
knight knight to a4 defending the c5
pawn but this is all very well known
theory bishop captures knight captures
and now we just win back the night with
this check queen delivers check goes
after the knight bishop d2 and queen
captures on c5 and now uh ding goes for
b4 this is incredibly sharp it has been
played before and if the pawn is
captured for example knight captures on
b4 we can play rook c1 and then well you
just don't want to play this against
ding especially if you don't have it
prepared let's say queen goes here e3
and now it looks uh very very uh
unpleasant most likely black will have
to allow white to capture this pawn with
the knight because if you further
capture then it's not going to be it's
not going to be pleasant so instead
after b4 queen to f5 and now there is a
game in the database where g4 was played
and this is a really awesome b for ng4
uh but the problem is even though it
looks extremely sharp after something
like queen e4 let's say queen b1 white
can force a queen trade or or force the
black queen to go to a to a silly square
so
ding doesn't want to allow this so
instead after queen to f5 we have rook
to c1 and it is now as of movie 11 that
we have a completely new game uh knight
to f6 uh by continuous development
prepares the castle and now rook c5
attacking the queen here queen to d7 and
now b5 uh challenging the knight here
knights the d8 and now bishop to b4 so
really putting pressure on black's
position uh asking black are you
interested in castling here and this
could be the absolute best move for
black but it's very hard to go after
this i mean the bishop is controlling
this diagonal the thing is if you castle
here ding would play something like rook
c1 open up and attack towards the rook
and after the rook moves play queen
captures on d4 win the pawn back and
after queen captures on b5 e3 now
opening up a discovery here attacking
the queen
and it would be well it would be a very
very uh dynamic game where ding would
have the bishop pair he's up in
development it would not be easy for
black to play this so instead knight the
e6 first attacking the rook rook to c4
and now knight to d5 attacking the
bishop here
and now ding captures on d4 we have
knight captures on b4 so he gives up
this very strong bishop will allow black
to castle rook captures on b4 and now
black castles king side and now finally
pawn to e3 uh defending this uh this
night so so far black is playing this
very well he still has this issue of
queen being on d7
he has to waste a move uh developing the
queen so he can develop the light for
bishop and then connect the rooks uh if
he can do that then black will be fine
so queen e7 this is how we do it we
attack the rook and now we can move our
bishop queen d2 developing while
defending and rook the d8 we have bishop
to e2 and now knight captures on d4 rook
captures on d4 and bishop to e6 now so
our rook can defend this rook as well
we have castles by being and now rook
capture sandy for queen captures on e4
and just b6 now so black
pretty much managed to develop all of
all of his pieces and the question is
what can being played here so uh
do you defend the pawn that's the
question uh as the bishop is attacking
the pawn and pretty much everyone would
just play a4 here automatically but then
you give black the open d file for the
rook and that means that you're probably
not going to win this game so ding
offers a pawn uh to go for for activity
he plays a rook to d1 now he grabs hold
of the d file and this means that black
can capture on a2 and this is definitely
the best thing for black so here by jin
she captures on a2 we have bishop to f3
now taking away the a8 square for from
the rook also you can go to d8 so rook
to c8 and now even bishop to b7 so now
we're slowly taking away squares from
the black rook of course if queen
captures bishop then we just deliver
checkmate of course everyone sees that
but just in case yeah so after this
should be seven rook to c5 and now comes
queen to d8 check it's not a offer of a
queen trade because if black captures
black just gets checkmated so queen to
f8 is forced and now h3 didn't create
some breeding room for his king because
the queen still cannot be traded off
black will get checkmated so bishop b3
forcing the rook away from the back rank
now rook to d4 and g6 now finally giving
the queen the king some breeding room
but this also means you allow a move
like queen to f6 now ding is threatening
rook to d8 which would end the game so
rook to f5 check uh going after ding's
queen queen to h4 and the noun
what do you play here well uh best for
black would be just rook to h5 point is
that if dink continues with queen f6 you
go back rook at 5 rook h5 rook 5 rook h5
and if you go something like queen to e4
then we capture on b5 and here if black
can resist white's attack then black has
two connected past pawns on the queen
side uh should be should be very good
for him the problem is after something
like queen d3 we are attacking the rook
and threatening rook to d8 so you have
to play queen to c5 to parry both
threats now let's say rook d8 check king
g7 and rook to c8 going after some back
rank ideas uh the problem is after queen
to b4 we can't play queen d8 but now
king h6 and black escapes but who would
see all of this and uh who would even
consider after all of this playing king
to h6 the queen here guards the f8
square so you cannot check the black
king and you are actually perfectly fine
here but that's the price of uh you know
uh of uh not being able to calculate all
of this so here queen the c5 was played
and it makes sense you really want to
get to the queen away from that uh back
rank otherwise you you would just lose
the queen but now dink is completely
winning but the move that is required to
win is so complicated and so crazy that
uh well i'm impressed that even ding
found it in in you know it's it's a must
play move uh so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this
incredibly difficult move to spot while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy you are a true master of the
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's bishop a8 i'm
only joking it is bishop to e4 that's
the move and uh
well what do you make of this uh the
point is if you you don't move the rook
a ding will just capture it and that's a
game over so
there's really nothing uh nothing to be
done there so the only option is to move
the rook uh where do you move the rook
okay the bishop controls this the bishop
controls this you you could play
something like maybe rook to g5 uh okay
if you try something like rook to g5
then obviously you get f4 so even more
squares will be taken away from the rook
uh if you play uh rook to h5 then queen
to f6 again we are just going after that
checkmate so the only move that makes
sense is rook to e5 but now comes the
real threat that the ding found the win
he played bishop to e4 and that is
bishop captures on g6 so you have to see
bishop e for bishop captures on g6 to
solve this obviously you have and
well
that's just it point is if h captures we
just play rook to d7 uh sorry not rook
37 rook to d8 check and now what do you
play here well you can start giving away
some pieces because after you move the
king just queen to h8 will be checkmate
so you're going to have to give up the
queen here and that's the game so
instead after bishop g6 if catherson g6
was played there is nothing better and
now rook to d7 now threatening queen
captures on h7 with check followed by
queen to f7 checkmate bishop to f7
blocking rook's attack of the h7 pawn
but now queen to f6 now we are
controlling these squares and the rook
to d8 again becomes a terrible threat
and there's no perpetual for black or
anything there's no way for the for
black to deliver any checks uh there is
a queen to c1 check which was actually
played in the game but after king to h2
he was in this position on move 36 that
the english uh or rather by june she
resigned in the game and a brilliant
brilliant victory for dean liran who
wins his fifth game in a row uh uh which
is simply incredible five classical
games in a row against strong
grandmasters uh
and you've seen how how well by jean she
played this uh it all came down to this
uh after queen to h4 does he find this
rook to h5 that leads to that mess of a
position that we discussed where the
king has to hide all the way to h6 uh or
some crazy line like that or he plays
just queen to c5 it seems like he he
solved everything but there is the
brilliancy bishop to e for bishop
captures and g6 which ding found and i
mean wow
incredible stuff and as promised uh we
said that we are going to discuss uh the
standing so these are the standings and
understandings or rather at the current
situation in the in the world so you can
see that being overtook furuja in the
live ratings but it's already 30th of
march so uh two more days and then the
ratings will be official so dean should
be uh the second highest rated player in
the world uh but it wouldn't really
matter because if um
even if uh furuja was higher rated than
ding uh firuj is already qualified for
the candidate so ding would be the
highest
highest rated player uh unless he drops
below uh arunyan which is very very
unlikely
so it's basically opting to just play
the required amount of games to be able
to qualify for the tournament but i just
thought it's been a while since we've
checked out the the world top 20. so
it's carl sanding ferruja karwana
arunyan wesley rapport and nyponyashi
mamidarov giri in 10 on 11 we have
nakamura also one of the participants of
the of the candidates tournament uh
rajab of also uh playing in the
candidates tournament uh dominguez perez
and topalov still hanging in there in
number 20. and uh these are the
candidates so far if you guys uh forgot
so ayani pognashi is playing in the
candidates tournament as he was the 2021
world chess championship runner-up then
taymor rajab he is a candidate nominated
by fiji uh because he would he qualify
for the previous candidates tournament
and then you know the whole covet
situation broke out and then he said he
will not play uh which was kind of the
correct decision as fide had to uh stop
the the candidates tournament and resume
it at some other point so it would
probably be best if they just you know
did it right away but okay fide felt bad
and then they offered him a spot in the
next candidates tournament uh then you
have the two finishers uh the two top
finishers of the chess world cup 2021 uh
they were a young sister of duda and
sergey karjakin
who is disqualified due to current
events um and he will be uh
replaced by whoever is uh well highest
rated and that is still to be decided as
you see in the end highest rating for
may 2022 which will probably be ding
liran uh then the two top finishers in
defeated grand swiss tournament of 2021
alireza firoj and fabiana corwana and
the two top finishers of the feeder
grand prix 2022 hikaru nakamura and
rihard rapport so those are the
candidates unless something spectacular
happens we now know all of the eight
candidates and we
uh uh think that it's gonna be it's
gonna be a great so uh we'll we'll see
if magnus will will stay true to his
words he uh or will he get motivated to
maybe even play someone else if even
alireza doesn't win uh the candidates
but i mean if if ding for example wins
the candidates tournament it's very
unlikely that magnus would not be
motivated to play against the ding i
mean he he he's a monster
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i will keep you informed of
course of ding's progress um
during this tournament uh so uh you know
stay tuned for that uh i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to aryan
bulgarian and i would like to thank rip
stefan arnold shelf uh pascal poirer
mladen jurich and adam tomczyk for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh the uh the
coverage of everything that's happening
in the chess world and of course
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all i will see
you soon have an excellent rest of your
day and do check out things immortal
first link in the description see you
soon